La siccità dell'estate 2022 è stata pare
la peggiore degli ultimi 500 anni con
laghi alpini vuoti e fiumi a secco che
si potevano addirittura attraversare a
piedi ma è una situazione che diventerà
sempre più comune se pensiamo che sei
degli anni più caldi della Storia sono
tutti nell'ultimo decennio
nemmeno il tempo di uscire dalla siccità
che ci siamo risvegliati nelle Marche in
una terribile alluvione con piogge mai
viste prima
siccità e alluvioni due facce della
stessa medaglia quella del cambiamento
climatico ma ci sembrano due problemi
opposti e quindi con soluzioni molto
diverse tra loro in realtà come Vedremo
hanno molti più punti in comune di
quello che pensiamo
negli ultimi mesi media italiani spinti
soprattutto da alcune associazioni di
categoria del mondo agricolo hanno fatto
di tutto per convincerci che la
soluzione per La siccità c'è ed è una
sola realizzare nuovi invasi ovvero
laghi artificiali si inizia a parlare di
laghetti piccoli serbatoi collinari
sostenibili senza cemento e poi in poco
tempo si è arrivati a chiedere a gran
voce nuove dighe lungo i corsi d'acqua
tirando fuori dei cassetti anche
progetti che erano stati abbandonati da
decenni
mentre l'acqua negli vasi sembra una
buona idea ma in realtà gli invasi hanno
molti problemi Innanzitutto perdono
tanta acqua per evaporazione in Italia è
come se buttassimo via Ogni anno il
primo metro dalla superficie di ogni
lago di ogni lago artificiale
Immaginate voi se foste nel deserto e vi
dicessero ti diamo dell'acqua per
sopravvivere nei prossimi mesi
effettivamente cosa fareste lascereste
in una pozza al sole
l'acqua degli vasi quindi soprattutto
quando sono piccoli Si si riscalda si
riscalda molto e temperature elevate
acqua stagnante viene a mancare
l'ossigeno e si possono sviluppare
fioritura legali e anche sostanze
tossiche sia per l'uomo che per la fauna
Acquatica e quindi a volte rischiamo di
accumulare dell'acqua che poi non avrà
la qualità sufficiente per essere
utilizzata
ma non è finita qui perché gli
sbarramenti che ci servono lungo un
fiume se vogliamo creare un lago
artificiale a Monte sono riconosciuti
come uno dei principali problemi
ambientali dei corsi d'acqua
Innanzitutto bloccano il passaggio dei
pesci che invece hanno bisogno di
spostarsi per sopravvivere e questo ha
creato delle totali estinzioni per molte
specie soprattutto quelle che hanno
bisogno di migrare per riprodursi
pensiamo nel Po allo storione oppure le
anguille che ormai non ci sono quasi più
da nessuna parte
Ma i fiumi non trasportano solo pesci
trasportano anche sedimenti
sabbia Ghiaia ciottoli che sono la
struttura portante del corso d'acqua se
questi vengono a mancare perché sono
bloccati a Monte e il letto dei fiumi si
incide sprofonda e sprofondando porta
con sé anche le falde che si abbassano e
viene a mancare acqua in superficie e
sprofondando fa Sì anche che l'acqua
salata dal mare penettri molto più
profondità lungo lungo i fiumi
e se alle Foci dei fiumi non arrivano
abbastanza sedimenti questi non si
disperdono lungo la costa e quindi le
coste si erodono e quindi peggiorano
ulteriormente il problema è legato a
livello medio del mare che si sta
alzando
e anche dei fiumi incisi vuole anche
dire canalizzarli di più e quindi
Sparare le piene molto più velocemente a
Valle creando rischio
quindi una supposta soluzione per
risolvere La siccità rischia in realtà
di creare più danni che benefici sia
quando di acqua ce n'è poca che quando
ce n'è tanta
di vari tipi di invasi poi ce n'è uno
che in particolare sembra rincorrere il
cambiamento climatico senza la speranza
di riuscirci sono quelli per
l'innevamento artificiale Chi di voi
scia
pochi bene
nell'arco Alpino saprete che fa sempre
più caldo e nevica sempre meno
a 1500 metri di quota si prevede che
entro 20 anni ci sarà il 90 per cento di
neve in meno
di queste basi Noi abbiamo già centinaia
ma moltissimi altri sono previsti però
li dovremmo riempire dovremo riempire
con acqua presa dai torrenti che sono
però sempre più a secco
perché sono senza acqua per le migliaia
di piccoli impianti idroelettrici che
abbiamo realizzato in questi anni e
anche perché avranno sempre meno acqua
perché verrà a mancare il contributo dei
ghiacciai quando si saranno sciolti
quindi rischiamo di rovinare il
paesaggio Alpino riempiendolo di vasche
vuote oppure piene d'acqua che non
riusciremo a usare perché farà troppo
caldo
Passando dalla siccità alle alluvioni
anche Qui l'idea diffusa e che possiamo
risolvere tutto con la forza con il
cemento quindi canalizzare i corsi
d'acqua dentro ad argini difese spondali
restringerli raddrizzarli piove sempre
di più e noi Costruiamo argini sempre
più alti
Ma se costruirò opere di protezione nei
centri urbani è una soluzione spesso
ragionevole altrove tante volte abbiamo
creato più danni che benefici abbiamo
trasformato i corsi d'acqua in piste da
bowling che sparano le piene velocemente
a Valle
e spesso abbiamo creato una falsa
sensazione di sicurezza perché dietro un
Argine Io sono protetto sono al sicuro
quindi Costruisco di più e quindi il
rischio aumenta perché quando succede e
prima o poi succede che un Argine si
rompa oppure che venga superato da una
piena i danni sono enormi e quindi ho
costruito un sistema che mi fa sentire
sicuro ma che in realtà è molto fragile
molti corsi d'acqua a cui non sono stati
solo canalizzati ma anche tombati è un
film tombato è una vera e propria bomba
a orologeria come abbiamo visto
quest'estate a Cantiano ma anche tante
altre volte siamo Livorno nel 2017 con
Riomaggiore oppure a Milano tante volte
all'anno con lo luna e ci sono migliaia
di chilometri di corsi d'acqua tombati
in Italia
un'altra convinzione diffusa è che
Versare al sicuro noi dobbiamo pulire i
fiumi
cioè Togliere tutta la vegetazione e
andare a scavare negli alberi e portare
via Ghiaia chi viene considerata
sistematicamente troppa anche se in
realtà spesso non è così Anzi il
contrario e abbiamo visto prima tutti i
problemi che crea la mancanza di
sedimenti
e tagliare la vegetazione allora è una
buona idea
dipende perché in alcuni casi gli alberi
possono aumentare il rischio se vengono
trascinati dalla corrente vanno a
intasare le pile dei ponti ma In altri
casi invece dove c'è più spazio in
particolare in pianura
gli alberi possono ridurre il rischio
perché rallentano l'acqua e riducono le
piene a Valle
e poi in molte situazioni
può essere più facile e anche meno
costoso sostituire un ponte invece che
continuare negli anni a rasare a zero
chilometri chilometri di vegetazione a
Monte
poi se viene a mancare la vegetazione
lungo le sponde che fa ombra a
temperatura dell'acqua aumenta e quindi
peggiorano i problemi legati alla
siccità quindi ancora una volta Vediamo
che le due questioni sono strettamente
legate
Quindi se una cura basata Soprattutto
sulle infrastrutture non funziona Che
cos'è che dobbiamo fare
a giugno di quest'anno mentre in Italia
sostanzialmente Si parlava solo di fare
dighe La Commissione Europea ha
pubblicato una proposta normativa si
chiama il pacchetto natura che ha molto
a che fare con la gestione delle acque e
del territorio
Secondo voi
parla di costruire nuovi sbarramenti
no esattamente il contrario parla di
rimuoverli di ripristinare La
connettività dei corsi d'acqua
di ripristinare migliaia di chilometri
di freeflow rivers cioè di corsi d'acqua
che scorrono liberamente
proprio per adattarci al cambiamento
climatico una cosa che peraltro si fa
già in diversi paesi europei pensiamo
che nel solo 2021 la Spagna ha rimosso
108 sbarramenti lungo i fiumi nello
stesso periodo in Italia che noi
sappiamo Zero
e poi queste proposte normativa parla di
agricoltura conservativa di salute del
suolo
perché un solo sano e in particolare il
ricco di sostanze organica è molto utile
sia per La siccità sia per le alluvioni
perché funziona come una spugna e
permeabile riesce a trattenere tanta
acqua e poi restituirla insieme ai
nutrienti e rendere disponibile per le
radici delle piante
oltre all'acqua che possiamo accumulare
nello strato superficiale di suolo il
sottosuolo ci fornisce un altro
osservatorio fondamentale le falde
acquifere e qui dobbiamo garantire che i
processi naturali di ricarica continuino
ad avvenire Quindi ad esempio la
dispersione dell'acqua lungo gli alberi
dei fiumi oppure durante le esondazioni
Ma se l'acqua dei fiumi
scorre perlopiù fino al 90% e per molti
mesi all'anno dentro i tubi perché la
deriviamo e le piene vengono incanalate
dentro ad argini sempre più alti e
continuiamo a impermeabilizzare il suolo
questi processi di ricarica naturale non
avvengono quindi noi dobbiamo
ripristinarli
e poi possiamo anche aiutare i processi
naturali realizzando delle ricariche
artificiali della falda facendo
circolare l'acqua quando ce n'è tanta in
zone dove si può infiltrare facilmente
tipo un'altra acqua che può aiutarci
molto per mitigare La siccità e sono i
nostri refoli fognari quando noi tiriamo
lo sciacquone per noi quello è un
rifiuto
in realtà è una risorsa enorme sia
idrica pensiamo che in Italia una volta
trattata potrebbe garantire quasi metà
della domanda irrigua del paese ma anche
in termini di nutrienti fosforo azoto
che sono preziosissimi
e quindi è davvero poco ragionevole
buttarli via infatti in alcune aree di
Europa già si usano più del 90%
delle acque reflue voi avete sentito
parlare durante la crisi di quest'estate
forse no a partire da giugno del 2023
saremo obbligati a farlo per una norma
Europea sul riuso delle acque in
agricoltura
poi chiaramente non possiamo solo
concentrarci sul lato dell'offerta
quindi aumentare la disponibilità di
acqua ma dobbiamo anche farlo dal lato
della domanda quindi gli usi tutti gli
usi ma in particolare quello agricolo
quello che ne consuma di più e quindi
qui certe filiere come quella del mais
del Rigo dell'azotecnico intensiva per
forza dovranno in qualche modo essere
rivisti È un tema molto vasto molto
complesso Ma dobbiamo comunque
ricordarci che l'impronta idrica quindi
l'acqua consumata cambia tantissimo da
un cibo all'altro
e quindi mitigare La siccità in futuro
dipenderà molto anche da quello che
decideremo di mettere nel nostro piatto
e nel territorio dobbiamo lavorare il
più possibile con la natura anche per
limitare i danni delle alluvioni e
quindi fare in modo che la vegetazione
rallenti le piene dove questo è utile
mantenendolo anche ripiantandola
rimuovendo opere che creano più danni
che benefici facendo in modo che si
dimenti riescano a arrivare il più
possibile fino al mare
ma soprattutto dobbiamo restituire
spazio ai fiumi ovunque possibile
perché gliene abbiamo tolto troppo e
perché in futuro sempre di più vedremo
fenomeni di pioggia che non avevo mai
visto prima che non riusciamo nemmeno
forse a immaginarci e che per fare meno
danni avranno bisogno di molto più
spazio di quello che c'è oggi
e dopo un evento eccezionale Pensiamo ad
esempio la tempesta vaia non possiamo
solo ricostruire tutto come prima
Ma dobbiamo sfruttarla quell'occasione
per rimettere in discussione il nostro
rapporto con i fiumi e con il territorio
dobbiamo
ampliare la cassetta degli attrezzi e in
questo le soluzioni basate sulla natura
sicuramente possono fare moltissimo per
aiutarci
ad adattarci i cambiamenti climatici
ricordandoci che non ci sono soluzioni
semplici e che valgono ovunque dobbiamo
ragionare a Scala ampia cercando di
capire caso per caso che cosa sia più
ragionevole fare
Grazie
[Applauso]